Maurice jones-drew NFL Network analyst
he's also the color commentator for the
Rams on radio former NFL running back
NFL 100 all-time team that series
premieres this Friday at 8:00 Eastern on
NFL Network revealing the running backs
best team in California right now is who
mojo that's a good one I'd probably have
to say the San Francisco 49ers right now
it's hard to say that but all right you
know what I even forgot about San
Francisco because I was talking about
the Chargers the Rams and the Raiders
how about the second-best team in
California not right I mean with all the
injuries of the Rams have and all those
thing I mean I'm gonna have to say the
Raiders it seems like both Bay Area team
drives we playing it very well their
schedule
the Raiders schedule is looking pretty
fortunate so they have life or a good
opportunity to keep winning games and
make the playoffs and the Niners are
just finding ways to win right now you
know obviously the Rams won last night
which was awesome and more of a
defensive battle game that defense is
playing well but they have kind of
injuries everyone knows their offensive
line to their receiving corps so they
they're trying to get healthy and
they're scratched and clawed but they're
finding ways to try to stay in this
playoff race which is good but I think
you're gonna have to win pretty much
went out to try to make the playoffs
this year how much doubt is there about
Jarrad golf this year I think it is it's
unfortunate that there's so much
attention put on Jared golf and and I
think a lot of people you know because
he played a quarterback atop money and
all these other things everyone saying
oh he's not playing well well this is
this is my when you kind of take a deep
dive into what's going on the first two
years you have to remember they had the
same starting five starting offensive
line somewhat I'm now on to say Jomon
Brown and deaf getting replaced by
Austin Blythe but it wasn't that big of
a deal like it was those guys played
well and they did their job they run the
ball play-action pass and Jared didn't
get much pressure in his face
over the last 10 weeks I think they've
had six different combinations of
starting offensive linemen and you know
you can't run your same game plan and I
think that was at which it was so
important last night to see the Rams
come out and something completely
different than they've ever ran before I
mean maybe they're a run first team they
played defense coaching they understood
that hey we got a short in this game and
we got a you know let our defense
witness will they run the ball three
times hunt that's ok which is very hard
for any offensive minded coach to do um
and you know Jared played exceptionally
well last night he had some he had some
really good throws I tend to hit the
ball 18 times he had some great shots
down the field
we had a 55-yard touchdown called back
where he put them and he did he'd do it
probably what we call you know and I
never heard we call that a tie or a dot
he'd do that out there and so I think
he's getting a lot of unfair criticism
because for any quarterback if you get
pressure in your lap it's hard unless
you're a mobile guy like Russell Wilson
or bar Jackson Sean Watson or carla
marie to kind of get out of the way and
get on the run and make a throw just not
Jared Jared is he a pocket passer he's
not trying to slide in the pocket a
little bit but if you can't step up and
step into your throws no one's ever
gonna be that good Maurice jones-drew
former NFL running back works for the
NFL Network joining us on the program
what's different about Lamar Jackson
this year as opposed to last year so
there's there's a bunch of things that
are different but it has zero to do it
Lamar Jackson I think first and foremost
the the Baltimore Ravens is also did a
phenomenal job really reaching out to
Louisville the University of Louisville
is there going on what they did to have
Lamar be so special in college now it
takes a lot for a pro Coast to do those
type of things to bring in some college
schemes and different things but you
have such an exceptional talent but you
have to be able to utilize what he's
have been able to do so that that's one
I think that was phenomenal
they went out and they really committed
to them so you know you bring in
different tight ends different type of
receivers speed guys that can run down
the field
because Lamar has expose a great deep
ball and let's throw those same passes
they went out and got a running back to
kind of complement what he does right so
you got your Thunder and Mark Ingram and
Gus Edwards to his lightning and so
really they they were all in which you
never see James do you know a lot of
teams aren't equipped to go all in on
that type of player but what you're
seeing now is the guy we saw a couple
years ago who threw for 4,500 and rushed
for 1500 and so you know right now he
they're playing with supreme confidence
and his ability to go out there and make
you play 11 on a football and his
ability to make people one person or two
people miss and the open field has been
the difference and so when you have to
account for a quarter rate that can run
and also throw the way he's thrown in a
team that's playing well it defensively
in special teams wise it'll be tough to
beat I mean I would have never thought
they'd put up 41 on the Houston Texas um
right but they I mean they are a they
are the team like I thought the the
Texas would tend to be an AFC and now
I'd like now my thought has changed
because Lamar Jackson has become the the
player that you cannot scheme for that
you try to scheme for you have one or
two guys on them but if you do that
similar what they'd Miami did he'll be
tuna in the air as well so I mean what I
would out what a draft right what a
pickup for them to come back in the
first round and pick him up and for him
to be playing the way he's playing why
do we have replay on pass interference
why doesn't the NFL just say you know
what we made a mistake here we're going
to table this always wants to be they
always want to try to be correct right
and so you got to understand the law
though or the rule behind the pass
interference like yeah as egregious as
it was in the NFC Championship game then
yes you can challenge that these guys
are challenging things that aren't that
egregious like like I get it that what
happened yesterday with Hopkins where
the guy was all over his back like yes
you gotta you should change that one
because but that's embarrassing mojo
like if if I don't see it in real time
and I see it on replay how do I
miss that on replay again they're trying
not to and this is one they don't want
that rule to affect the outcome of the
game they want to make sure that if the
game is changed again like the the where
the tail will be coming literally like
runs through the the receiver and they
don't call it my destiny you can
challenge and they'll take it back so it
was so egregious some of these ones that
people are challenging I mean guys are
hand fighting but you can call people to
understand you can call holding and
passing their parents on every play if
you want to but it has to be so bad that
you know like a guy has to get blown up
before the ball gets there or something
like that in order for them to really
it's kind of like an overturn it it's
embarrassing and and you're there that
they should they should never have
implemented this in the first place
you just had a horrible color in the
Rams Saints game that's all you just had
a horrible I I agree with you like
people this is the funny thing people
first of all and in our society we
always want someone to blame right when
things don't go away we always want to
find someone to blame instead of looking
at within is they you know what if I'm
the Saints we had opportunity and
overtime to try to win this thing we
didn't do it right or or and other other
deals like oh there's times those calls
are missed my game that were on the ramp
side as well like a face mask on jer
golf but you can't you can like
everyone's human people make mistakes
but for some reason in our society it's
okay to blame put blame on someone else
like no look we're good hey bro like you
got the ball person over time maybe
maybe if you were to stop worrying about
the pie and focus on the game and not
throw a pic right you might have won and
so I just think you know for a lot of
people is easy to blame the rest all the
rest of it's horrible there are there's
human beings and if you're if you're
down on that field and you you see how
fast these guys are running and you see
how like quick things are moving like
they're they're they're taught and
trained to see certain things and
they're doing their best to do that but
sometimes they miss things like people
miss stuff everyday in their life and so
you know I've never been one to blame
the rest but if we have an opportunity
to clean it up
mojo and we don't do it
then we're doing a disservice to what
we're trying to you know get right
remember I completely agree with you Dan
I gotta I don't I don't think that that
rule should've been put in place yeah I
think that you should have said look we
made a mistake it happens we move
forward yeah I would love for them to
say that now just say upon further
review we made a mistake here and we're
gonna table this until we figure out how
to how to maybe announce it over the PA
during it during a game the NFL always
sides with the fans like that if the
fans want something it feels like the
fans get something if I said to fans do
you want to continue to have pass
interference review I'm gonna guess 90%
would say let's let's get rid of this
rule because you don't you don't
implement it correctly so let's just get
rid of it and then the NFL can say hey
upon further review we're gonna get rid
of this rule well I think they'll play
they'll probably talk about that at the
next chapter in a competition although
this is they know people have to
understand this even when I was playing
which you know a couple years ago if you
saw a penalty that wasn't a penalty or
you saw a tunnel that wasn't called
you could turn it into the league and
the league would send it back and tell
you either yes we messed up or no this
was the right call and I've lost games
because of that and they're not one game
because of it and so it always balances
itself out like it doesn't it doesn't
you know I've won a couple games because
of some calls that we didn't get or that
we got and there I lost some games
personal calls we didn't get and then
you go and turn it in and then nobody
like yeah sorry you guys I shoulda got
this call and it could have affected the
outcome in the game but it is what it is
and and and so the league has done been
doing that for years and so I think
trying to to to make these correct these
these different calls in the course of
the game where there's time because you
get remember the NFL's not trying to
make the game any longer they're trying
to keep it between three and a half or
four hours yeah and so you're when you
start being able to challenge everything
and instant replay this and that the
game is gonna continue to stretch out
and so they're trying to find a way to
condense these games as well I'd finish
this sentence before I let you go if the
Chargers win tonight
oh that's uh who they got a chance to
[Laughter]
know it's funny you say that
first of all Melvin Gordon's back
running well which is good I'm glad to
see that but the Chargers the way like
it's crazy the way they treat their
players of an organization right like if
I'm if I'm a and I said this before
if Melvin Goins loved our better players
and I get it you may have a different
value on them but if this is a year like
we've been hearing like oh this is their
year they're in their four year window
with Phillip Rivers like we got to go
get it we got to make these things
happen
why wouldn't you just pay them and this
understand a junior four year window and
you're just trying to get there instead
of having this long drawn-out holdout
all these different things going on you
lost two or three games because you
fumble the ball on the 1-yard line right
like all these different things could
have been out you can still you did you
could have really been in the race in
the hut and so I think for me if they
win the night they're back in it but
they they're they doesn't show such a
big hole that they have to they have to
climb out of a tough place yeah because
the Raiders are you know their schedule
seems yeah I think they seem like they
got a decent schedule they're
user-friendly yeah you call it user
friendly yeah I call it Raider friendly
okay nice it's a nice schedule you get a
lot of your tough opponents at home too
which is which is awesome yeah it's
tough to go from east coast to the west
coast it's good to talk to you what do
you bench in nowadays you know I haven't
really I haven't been so I'm working on
trying to get to the Spartan Race so I'm
not really going for uh I'm not really
going for like I guess like like tough
wait like 300 pounds or anything I'm
doing
we have 16 right now so I just did 225
15 times yeah I'm just trying to try to
get endurance I'm trying to build my
endurance if that's okay that's not bad
but I got a guy on my staff who does
that I know listen I you know it's crazy
a lot of easier to go play the NFL then
I mean there's a lot of guys I can't do
that Chris MacGyver did it eight times
yeah okay wait you're calling on
McCaffrey it sounded like you were
calling it a Christian McCaffrey is
being soft floppy and ball and think he
can do I would never say that
he's right now himself and Dalvin cook
they're doing a great job of carrying
the torch for the backs and then you
know lousy see Kelly and all these other
guys are bringing in their their part as
well but it's very interesting to see
Christian McCaffrey being like one of
the only weapons on the Panthers oh he's
doing this amazing so hopefully you can
keep it up and win that MVP which I know
it's gonna be tough with a little more
tour but he's doing some exceptional
stuff and endowment as well good you
talk to you mojo always good to see you
always good to talk to you well I see
you this year the Super Bowl I'll be
there I don't know the Rams will be
there you know if the Rams were first of
all the Rams they sneak in and get in
these playoffs but they're looking like
they're changing a little philosophy may
be able to do that okay
you best believe they get in that dance
we-we-we when I say that I'm not French
we we we we will see you in the Super
Bowl
Thank You mojo alrighty later that's
Maurice jones-drew NFL Network analyst
Rams apologist former NFL running back
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]